what's up guys my name is Samuel Leeds
and welcome to this week's winners on a
Wednesday where every single week I
bring one of my success students and
they share their story one of the best
ways for you to learn is to learn not
just from me but also from my students
and this guy Pierce he was actually one
of the very first few interviews on
winners on a Wednesday it's been over a
year since he's been on the show so I'm
gonna bring him back we're gonna see
exactly what he's up to today and get a
perspective of a slightly more
established property opener
[Music]
dude second time on winners Wednesday
yeah we'll ask me why do I bring people
back because you've got a new story now
when we met before you you'd only been
going like six months yeah and you've
gone if this is all from memory you tell
me four wrong you came on the crash
course you join the Academy you got
you've got some serviced accommodations
which will making you like three grand a
month
yeah financial freedom cool you're still
working on the business but you know
full-time in property life changing
story and if I don't want to watch that
we'll leave a link for your part one but
now I can't not have you back because
you've achieved so much more now take me
through it thanks for having me back
again Samuel I think you've just
mentioned what it was like last year
when I first joined the Academy yes -
cause knowing you - now completely
different being a more for property
entrepreneur rather than just learning
the business at that 20:19 was I think
we got our transfer learning a lot more
well not 2099 220 1820 when did you late
late 2018 yes
October yeah okay cool yeah so then I
think I assure my Academy in yes about
November that 2019 so when you finish
the Academy you never finish it because
yeah we don't yeah you have the friends
that Network the education that never
stops I mean I think the learning part
stops yeah but oh it doesn't stop but
you're still learning from your peers
and stuff but yeah so that's room yeah
the classroom things are gone yeah let's
go back into what we what I was doing I
was running a service accommodation
visit well I mean I am running a service
accommodation business but at that point
it was just really learning and actually
getting into knowing the deals and how
to stack up and stuff
coming down I think we're after my
winners on Wednesday I think about Jan
in March something a little bit
different happened in life and that was
my father got meningitis got a little
bit ill ill to a point that he go into
ICU and all this which yeah which what
what's basically happen is at that point
I had to go into hospital for a month
with
because he was in the hospital and we
just sat down you know I had a business
of service accommodation but nothing
else I was just sitting there with dad
spending time with him trying to train
for him to get back you know into a
normal life and the reason why I'm
saying this is at that point I used to
sat down next to him and I'm thinking
what's next for me so in terms of I'm
sitting there do nothing and that's
always started from a sourcing
perspective I sat down there next to dad
with my laptop we used to talk and then
and yeah I used to do some work and then
that's when I clicked myself saying
actually I'm sitting there doing pretty
much nothing and I should be making the
most at this time
so while I was with dad in hospital I
started well in Academy we learned
register care and sourcing business when
you say sourcing packaging deals passing
on to invest yeah Oh active income but
massive nom massive yeah active income
but the way I did was i sat down and I
thought what is in the market already
and how can I be different yeah and
that's when I started dual sourcing but
as a bespoke investor club yes oh rather
than going out there finding deal and
put into an investor list I used to just
because of what I've done in my my
industry in terms of service
commentation business I was getting a
lot of people asking me saying I want to
start to but how do I do this how do I
find a deal how do I do that so they
just go straight to you and get ya so
rather than doing all so that we I set a
plan so to to make it different really
to start up a bespoke investor club
where I actually find a deal and walk
them through the setup actually showing
them the the business of service
accommodation rather than being a source
out there who can just say here you go
there's a deal yes the numbers letting
people shadow use a great thing about
figures so you serviced accommodation
your own service accommodation business
yeah if I remember is all about 3000
yeah how is that going now is that still
it's actually uh it's actually gone down
for one reason and I'll tell you
actually you'll be very surprised so my
first Union that I got which was the
block yeah I had a break Clause of two
our months
yeah and the landlord decided to take
out and do it himself
okay but you know what fair enough I am
I'm happy with that
yeah he's now my competition in the same
yeah and but at the same time off go
active active income coming through yes
sourcing which is like you said so has
my properties did you have when we spoke
so what I only had one deal at that time
which is a block of four yes and that
got taken away from me have you replaced
it with with another three okay yeah
from your at the moment averaging on to
2500 okay so yes so basically because I
think what people want to know as well
and people watch the ants is sometimes
people come on the windows Wednesday and
they've only been in the game six twelve
months yeah they do really well yeah
people love to see people that have been
in a little longer like yourself a bit
more established you've now been in the
game a year or two yeah
and seeing that it's still going well
okay you've lost that you lost now and
you've replaced and that's that's
exactly what I want to show to people as
well is did I know at that point I'd
actually lose that deal you know a year
later probably not and you know if I was
going to actually grow grow grow grow
but that was a stopping point where I
went
when landlord went actually I want my
properties back I'm sat there thinking
okay now but I think about business you
know and there's people out there that's
what I want to show people that it's not
just the goods of service accommodation
what are the challenges do we get in and
the setbacks do we get in service
accommodation what's the biggest
learning point you've had from the whole
process of serviced accommodation I mean
it's a business that's why I you know
although it's a property investing
strategy I've also learned to run a
whole business of service accommodation
and that could be you know it's just not
you know opening a service accommodation
puttin Airbnb and going live it's it's
all about how do you deal with your
people which is you know who do you deal
with sources agents your clients we talk
about branding and marketing how
important it is
the accelerated coaching and mentoring
yeah and I forced you to do a video yeah
that was your first ever video I had it
was it was around Christmas times in a
year ago it was the next to a Christmas
tree I say sheepishly next to a
Christmas tree very nervously putting
out a video like boom and I saw so much
potential in you and now just seeing you
as a person how you've grown as well
because I think ultimately you've said
it you said it dealing with people
agents branding I think a property
business is a people business and people
forget that people think you know it's
all about the property but actually
money always comes from people yeah the
properties of vehicle the money is going
to come from the guest source from the
landlords from the investors from the
buyers from it's coming from people or
the tenants it's coming from people it's
not actually coming from the property
and I think that's something that I I
know you've learned yes you become such
a great communicator and I see you do
videos and putting posts out engaging
with people networking and I think okay
you were making 3,000 passive income
that's now dropped to two and a half
thousand you've got the skill yeah you
know source and how much you're making
money sourcing side of things so just in
last year I made about thirty thirty
call so that's like doubled now yeah so
what I did was the beauty of sourcing
with bespoke investor club is you
actually well I actually package it on
the way we planned the whole 12 weeks
process and it's not like just going out
there sourcing and give it to them it's
actually planning in that cube that
allows me to plan my sourcing business
as well because this would you say to
someone who wanted to do sourcing yeah
what would you advise because I know a
lot with the sort that we teach heavily
on the crash course and Academy how to
source you've kind of found your own
niche yeah and you do get a little
different to a lot of people which is
awesome and everyone cos will put their
own personality on it what would the
steps be to someone watching this it's
thinking good
I want a source deal yes how I speak to
that you know what I think when I first
started I it all fell down to a little
bit of knowledge that's 100 percent sure
I had a bit knowledge which is being in
service accommodation business but if
somebody's fresh new into it just go and
learn yeah
learn a little bit first and then to be
proven just work with people around you
and that's the big if you
on a call source with someone do it for
free yes what does that mean what does
that mean so what that means is you will
work with somebody you'll do the work
you'll find a deal on behalf of her
you've got to be a legal source
obviously yeah you can call source with
somebody who's already got a client
database yes that's the way they want to
go and find a good deal stack it up work
with those source of that can stack it
rien and then send it to their clients
yeah and that's how you're gonna build
trust at the end of the day I have I've
learned one thing in my sourcing
business is my clients have trusted me
through the process of you know service
accommodation and the results I've given
them the results I've got in my business
helps a lot because I can show them what
I've done I can tell them this is how
I've done yeah and also show them that
look I'll help you achieve that by with
my knowledge and source you the right
product that you want so you so you
mentioned sourcing a deal for free which
i think is really interesting because
most people think all always to always
act in terms of trading their time for
money yeah Robert Kiyosaki says yeah
actually work for free yeah because if
you can pass someone a deal for free
yeah but that person is then gonna go
like the thing you've got going for you
now as a sorcerer is you've got a
reputation yeah you've passed deals it's
work just people trust you yeah if you
started from scratch how's about package
and pass a deal and so on for free yeah
don't charge yeah but just ask for a
story in exchange 100% and it will only
take you a week to do that as well it
won't take you a lot and then certainly
you've now got a customer you've got a
story yeah you only need one testimonial
to suddenly gain credibility a hundred
percent you know what about service
accommodation you have any regrets why I
don't have any regrets actually but what
I do is I always think about a thing
you've taught us in the journey of
Academy as well is to think ahead you
know like we used to make one step you
made ten steps yeah and that's why I've
now started looking at you know a lot of
people have asked me this question about
why have you not grown in the way you
should grow and I think that I wanted to
bring this actually because I am so when
was it through my last winners on
Wednesday I think in Feb my newspaper
article came out
and if you remember yeah I do yeah so
ultramel had my ass you cuz a lot of
news reporters watch this channel yeah
and yeah if they if they see good
stories yeah picked up yeah and then
either it was in it was actually
headline in the front of newspaper
anyway so what happened was I randomly
got a call from a property developer
local I know off and he said his I'm
seeing this what's happening like what
are you doing now so he invited me for
coffee out his own and I kinda knew what
was going and he he's a is an
entrepreneur he's been in property for
the last 10 15 years yeah he knows
property very well and if he can make
some income somewhere where which is
gonna excel his portfolio he will do
that so he called me and said right I
fancy doing it with you do you want to
grow and I took I turned down hundred
thousand investment why what did you do
it down so now go back inside and if you
remember I used to own a stage and
yellow in venture with lay agent letting
agent yeah and a joint venture went
completely very very wrong within your
letting agency so you in the business
that you said that the business that we
set up after two years do you go but
when we met you were doing that but I
was about to leave at that point yeah
really self yeah so that didn't settle
really well so I had to obviously from
our perspective we had to move move
apart so I was the one who walked away
from the business
yeah and from that I've actually for
people out there who want to do joint
venture it's taste it's given me a
little bit of bad taste
yeah off do I see
if I if I get somebody's hundred
thousand investment and how do I
actually now put down relationship
before five years ten years and that's
probably much more important to me at
the moment rather than just the money
side of it because one hundred thousand
would have scaled me to big numbers yeah
last year very big numbers last year
especially I wish I'd picked up the
phone but I would have I would have
helped you with that because it's really
interested in what you say and I think
the thing is when you have a bad
experience yeah it's a bit like if
someone has a bad experience with a
sorcerer and then they go on they're
buying from a source of again ever yeah
well actually you can learn from it and
you can actually don't make the same
mistake again and the same way you add
about experiencing to invent yeah yes
then are you going Windows Wednesday if
you go the newspaper some big developer
goes I want to give you a hundred grand
let's do some business together and
you're like I did a joint that you
before I didn't work out and I think it
was too fresh as well so that that's
probably where you know now yeah I'm now
coming out of it again yeah to scale up
when maybe after this interview have
someone asking to give you two hundred
thousand I've got to be sensible and
that now yes but 100 percent and for
joint venture this is where I've said to
a lot of people now please believe that
it's just not the money side of it is
the relationship how how both people can
add value to it as well yeah so from
from regrets point of view that's
probably because if you didn't feel that
it was your season and if you felt like
you know I'm not in the right place to
serve you the best yeah I know you can
but right now I can't serve you the best
maybe you can go back to him that yeah
and say you know at different place yeah
and you know I think sometimes sometimes
leaving money on the table is not a bad
thing because building a credible
relationship is always better than
building a pot of money yeah because
then the money will follow
yeah I agree so I did a lot of stuff
come from ones Wednesday last time did
you yeah yeah and I was how many of uses
that had views yeah
the interview had 21 K 21 thousand views
at plus all across the newspapers
newspapers would have a mini celebrity
yeah because I got a call from well
actually I also got a call from a guy
who owns an off licence and had the that
a newspaper delivered as well yes so I
use it I was getting random call from
people random call from other business
people who's read the newspaper yeah so
yeah that that was that's one of the
opportunities from the Academy as well
like you come to the crash course that's
what it all starts at the cash box right
it does yeah like that's where you're
gonna get bang over punched in the face
with knowledge yeah
doors opened but then on the Academy
what's the difference
it says it all you just you are now then
holding accountable of learning into
details of property business yeah I
still remember the first time we had at
that point we had a launch pad yes yeah
being a quadrant q1 q2 q3 II set some
goals up and do you know what what a
clear picture that was yeah I still had
it in my whiteboard you know I went home
put it on a whiteboard and to end of
2019 I still had it
I actually took you off literally out at
the end of the year yeah because I think
probably I think I'd say about 90
percent of the goals were achieved the
only one that I didn't achieve which
you're probably getting to be upset off
was doing a joint venture with someone
as well that's crazy that was the one
thing yeah because financially free from
went to service domination which you did
yeah deal saw sent to build up extra
cash flow to then invest into property
and then joint venture with some joint
venture that was the one which I didn't
achieve so what your plans in 2020 um
sort of so I think about September
August time I've been well I've been
looking at some bar refocus refinance
program cool and buying and she's doing
it so so we've got a pot of money now
which we might be able to start myself
not a lot about per 35 okay just when
you started yeah yeah so yeah so yeah so
bit pot money that I can work with 2020
I think I want to also look at maybe now
think about a scaling in bigger joint
venture rather than so for example
taking a landlord who okay actually
somebody who's making a say they're
converting a flat say five or ten flats
on the joint venture with them yeah to
actually turn into a service elimination
business mhm so I need to open my you
know after that hundred thousand
investment now I let down again yeah it
will come again but yeah so the normal
thing is I still want to run mine you
know service accommodation business yeah
as successfully I was it so can I still
want a source yeah if people the
opportunity of actually understanding
service accommodation business running
service documentation business and you
know be it be able to tap into my
knowledge to get some good deals but I
think that the biggest challenge for me
is to do a joint venture and Kelly art
pin to you what do you think's going on
with the service accommodation
is still ripe ah no I think that so I
think good people will find good
sorcerer or good people who's got good
service accommodation knowledge would
still find good deals you just got to
get the knowledge yeah it's a lot of
HMOs people say oh it's oversaturated
it's like it's oversaturated if you do
it wrong or if you do it in the wrong
area but if you do the right area in the
right way believe me it's not over
saturated because there's people on
spare-room looking for new rooms in
there dozens every single hour
absolutely agreed so how could it
possibly be oversaturated it's all about
supply and demand
believe me the demand is there the
supply is there as well if so how can we
be better than the current supply how
can we find areas that are untapped into
yeah what do you think it's the same
serviced accommodation oh I agree
completely agree I think I I think there
is in the last few we probably know in
the last few months or in especially in
2019 there's a huge growth and service
accommodation business yes
special thanks to you I guess obably I
know 100% probably is true and you know
a lot of people have got an opportunity
to run service accommodation business
but at that same time when people say oh
I'm a little bit worried about now what
do I do you know is it the right thing
to invest it's like any business there's
a coffee shop down the road there still
have another coffee shop opening you
know so if you've got a passion and I
think it all falls down to if you've got
that interest your mindset your passion
into it and you want to start that
you'll do it regardless how do you feel
about that landlord who you were making
3 grand a month off turning around up in
the bright doors and saying actually you
know what I'm reduced myself you know I
think at that point I I had to think
from a business perspective rather than
personal perspective yeah because from
personal perspective on thinking
actually you've taken home rent from me
found out that he works right and then
now you're now used you as a guinea pig
yeah literally
and almost exploited yeah so now from a
business point of view from a business
perspective I I looked I and I said
things like this happens in business and
have I got a chance to move on hundred
percent yeah you know but you had full
with him I was giving you three grand a
month yeah he just pulled it from me
yeah like basically and he didn't do
anything wrong because it was it was
legally he had a bright clause but
really took away your whole yeah chunk
chunk income because at that point I had
other other units which I was very lucky
that last year I managed to find to
Airbnb well to serviced apartments yeah
which was run by landlords and they gave
up and I found them either through gum
tree or open rent nice I took you on
yeah and then I made it work yeah so
when people give up on units I like to
take them yeah because this is wrong
probably they're doing it wrong so many
people do it wrong because you know why
because they watch a couple YouTube
videos yeah the hair a few stories yeah
they go and have a bash I'm all for
telling people go for it go for it but
always go for it with the correct
training yeah because otherwise you're
like getting into a car as a 17 year old
yeah and having a go having a bash do it
man go crazy don't just have any
instructors that with you yeah and and
that that's where a lot of people like
you said landlords are had done it but
then they are starting giving up because
the stock level of service departments
going up other people who no service
part mean well are doing well yeah and
there's you know there's a lot of you
know Aging's are put in properties back
up in the market from landlords and you
can see the pictures
towels are rolled up did you see my
financial freedom challenge in London
yeah so alright within a day a serviced
accommodation regiment I'd an agent safe
to me I'll give you properties like how
do you so how do you get agent stickers
used to be an agent yeah you've done the
train down how do you get agents to give
you a proper to actually oh I think if
you're stuck there's two things if
you're starting fresh then there's a
little bit of challenge to work around
it but at the moment I I just call them
and I say this is what I do yeah service
accommodation and this is what I've been
doing this this are the agents I've
worked with you know I've worked with
winkworth Chancellor's all the marketing
cows
I have literally I'll put their name on
the table and say I've worked with them
good and they all of a sudden they were
okay cool would you mind taking us a
reference from them I'm not feel free I
know what your first deals always your
hardest yeah I always say this because
once you've got your first deal even if
it falls through yeah it doesn't matter
because now you've got your deal
now you can use that as a reference and
that says this is how I've done it
before yeah this is who I've worked with
yeah this is how it plays out absolutely
you in and and this is where my my
current bespoke investor clubs then join
my service because not only they're
getting the unit they get in
relationship with the agent because
they've now taken over and there they've
got direct contact with the agents and
I've told them now if you find another
deal just tell the other agent that
you've worked with this agent and
they're happy to give you some reference
yeah and all of a sudden you've got more
credibility
I think first deals always the artist
yeah and I think as well people don't do
business with you
because of fear because there's any if
they smell that you're fearful yeah like
if you're like this before but I'm just
you need confidence and I think
confidence comes from knowledge and
that's why we put this these videos out
and we do the training all right
top three tips if you were telling your
two year young or eighteen month younger
self yeah about property getting into
property what are the top three things
you'd say okay so the first one I would
say because I I took actions that's
that's probably from from a knowledge
perspective I should have taken action a
lot lot faster so in terms of coming to
your crash course if I knew I saw your
video I knew I liked you I should have
gone straight away
why should add that I waited another six
months yeah oh yeah to say actually I
want to go to crash course I've wasted
the whole whole year
yeah I could have interests in common so
probably people watching this video even
now have been watching it for a year
yeah it's so some day I'll probably go
to a crash course yeah now you just say
no no just do it now because I wasted a
whole six I think I remember seeing your
videos probably seven months from there
to actually come into our crash course
at that at that time actually you had
very less crash course as well so and I
was one of them I had to go to the
London one not the
in Birmingham Drive yeah yeah you know I
learned from it yeah so now if I know
and that was a massive turning point for
you on that yeah that weekend yeah okay
so so that's probably the first one the
second one use your use your knowledge
to be able to action things quickly yes
so so now if you've got knowledge or
you're about to get knowledge action
quickly don't sit down and think okay I
still need a little bit more knowledge
to do something yeah so I think if
you've got that ABC that you know off
yeah and you X don't think about the
rest yes
just go into it so I love that so the
first look just the best example is if
you're thinking about how do I run
service accommodation business but you
don't have a deal yet think about how do
I need to get that deal first yeah if
it's just picking up the phone calls to
agents do it brilliant so basically as I
say don't worry about the XYZ yeah just
walk the ABC maybe say here and then
you'll figure it out yeah
so I love that because so many people a
lot but who's gonna pay the insurance
and what's this case like that's not
your problem line yeah your problem
right engine having landlords yeah your
problem right now is you don't have any
agents you know anything you're not
viewing any houses yeah so just just
just action the one person that you want
to achieve our for that hundred percent
yeah and I think that's probably just in
the both of you first two points well
come on to third in a minute I'll give
you some time to think about it
interesting that the both speed yeah and
I think the speed is so important in
2020 I tell you who's gonna win the fast
movers yeah the fast movers are gonna
win 21 and bi put up a state us through
the day and I said why take 12 months to
do something that can be done in a day
and people actually try to argue with me
they were like no patience it's good to
take the time sometimes it might be yeah
it depends on the context but 90% at the
time no no the fastest person win wins
and people mess around you saw what I
did in the day in London yeah anyone
that's not watch the video again I'll
put like a card up or we'll leave a link
in the description but you can do very
you can achieve a lot of stuff very
quickly you can think about it for
I think about calling agent what I say
let me look on this house right move let
me think about this and then yeah or you
can just do it do it and I think the
people that do things fast yeah I mean
believe me if you're a business owner
and you're running a property portfolio
you know I mean I have 42 members of
staff I've been a very successful
property company you do now as well
you've got to make fast decisions I'll
come to a business meeting all I'm doing
is making fast decision I'm not messing
around having conversations about
hypotheticals and trying to put off the
important stuff the real the stuff that
you really need to do here's or people
do the stuff that's really important ie
making phone calls putting forward
offers attending seminars that really
important stuff people don't do that and
instead they do other stuff instead
which makes them feel good yeah because
it's like all I'm being busy know you're
a busy fool yeah you need to do this so
love that all right point three point
three I'd say just a few I mean now I
think from a business perspective quite
a lot is if you if you really want to do
something and you see there's a
potential in it think about three years
and five years and if that ticks off
both the box that you want to see
yourself in again take actions yeah just
literally take action yeah and I think
another thing as well I'll add a point
for to that is branding tell the world
you're a property investor so rule
number one I said this year yeah
that's rule number one tell the world
what you're doing because people think
I'm gonna do it secretly and then when I
get some success then I'll tell people
because I don't want to tell them
upfront because they don't look stupid
if it doesn't happen yeah but actually
what that I realize is that when you
speak it out you speak it into existence
and when you begin to get deals and
success you need to tell people you've
branded yourself really really well what
happened like what would you say to
people that are successful because
believe me I have to drag people and
Wednesday people there's so many people
that are financially free and they're
like I don't know when it's Wednesday
because I don't want my family to come
to me for money
because I'm not very good on camera yeah
well I don't think my story I'm not
making for around a month but I think my
story is powerful enough yeah you know
and I'm like serious you don't realize
that when you put yourself out there
come on winners Wednesday actually
what's gonna happen is people are gonna
you're gonna snowball the success yes
solo what would you say to people like
that
oh I mean one thing I know about you
know my journey has been you know the
reason we're in the last 18 months got
all this opportunities is through my
branding and marketing yeah you know
being able to come in to winners and
Wednesday that I think I was the fifth
or the sixth one well yeah yeah yeah the
very first one so so at that point I
still remember when you said piers
you've got to come in I didn't know yeah
I remember I still remember with Hampton
office I'm like Samuel I'm not ready for
it you like to just do it yeah and you
know what that that actually gave me an
opportunity of actually growing my
business because after that video I went
and did hundred other videos boy
yeah so and that was my breaking point
of being in a video at yeah and yeah
I've done loads of videos I did a free I
think my one of the successful video I
had was I did know obviously we've been
talking Academy to give value yeah so I
did a free Google my business for
service department video he posted on
service accommodation Network and I had
over 2k views all-organic
500 people commenting but you know what
as well they you've got going for you
which i think is really good some people
when they become successful and there's
not like you know making money from
property they don't want other people to
compete with them so they'll keep it
really quiet okay
and I even have this people come on the
crash course go through the Academy they
become financially free and then
suddenly they're like Samuel I think you
should start charging people for the
crash course why don't you hold back a
bit on YouTube and the truth and the
truth is their their heart their spirit
is a competitive spirit and they don't
want other people to succeed just
because but then it's like well hold on
if it wasn't for the free crash course
and YouTube videos you wouldn't be where
you're at yeah whereas your heart and
your spirit is to see people succeed and
you've had a rippling effect throughout
the Academy you've done really well it's
great to see I'm sure people we're
really glad to see that you're still
doing well you still making money what
would be the the kind of like the final
pieces of advice encouragement that
you'd give to people that are just
getting started in their job yes so I
think
I said this in my first interview as
well as is where where I if I'd never
had gone back and to all this actions of
going and getting those knowledge first
of all I would have never been where I
am today
yeah and that's not just you know you've
opened my mind to learn more just not be
property industry or be anything
branding and marketing on I'm quiet you
know at the moment I like branding and
marketing I'm learning that as well and
what I've seen at the moment is be open
to learning yeah and be open to to
actually look forward to your growth if
you if it means you find a mentor and
that you want to pay them and actually
get them you know trying you to get the
right knowledge in short space of time
yeah you do it and that's probably the
biggest thing I can give anyone is just
take action get some knowledge yeah and
just you know what have fun I think
that's probably what I've done in 2019
I've had loads of fun I was in Nepal for
27 days for my cousin wedding hopefully
when the first came back on the 27th had
an amazing blast with family and it's
all about you know balancing me out yeah
but the main thing having time to do
that like spending a month in Nepal
having a blast you've also had to spend
a month with your dad in the hospital
yeah which is obviously the other side
to it but that's been their fee family
when you when you read today and I guess
if it wasn't for the for your property
income that wouldn't be impossible oh
yeah and and you know I think that's
where my now I look at it dad's feeling
better as good than ever he's recovered
and everything but he's actually just
retired as well so I surprised them with
a business class flight Nepal so they
had the blasts of the blasters and
pictures in a minute but yeah to be able
to do that for parents oh yeah that's
like that just felt good yeah that's a
good feeling is a good feel how does it
feel now like 18 I was like I do do well
oh you know what I am Who I am you know
I I'm happy I'm liking what I'm doing
but to be able to - I think from a
bigger picture look at from what life is
for family or things like that it's I
never thought I would be doing that and
you know 18 months ago yeah I mean I
think that you making 30 grand a year
from from your packaging deals you're
making about 25 30 grand a year from
from from your income yeah I mean for
some people that's the dream right there
you know you can always find people that
are more successful than you and be like
oh my gosh I'm actually not that
successful but actually you're how old
28 28 28 years old I mean that's a
massive massive achievement so I'm
really glad to see you smile and also
look at what life could have been like
yeah you know your business kind of
failed yeah don't mention didn't work
out you died an ill how do things if you
hadn't have had property to go to each
other and who knows what would we what
your life would be yeah 100% and unless
just I think you probably agree with
this I mean if I had to take a month
away if I was employed with dad being a
hospital I just said to my brother I
said that morning my you know my brother
took off he is quite flexible with his
work but if I had to call my work and
say I can't come because my dad's ill
they wouldn't really been following this
yeah they would probably find me and
especially you know at that point I'll
probably had to make a decision of going
work I've seen dad in hospital like that
so a being in month next to dad 6:00 in
the morning till 10:00 in the evening
doing what I like through my laptop and
having you know a great relationship
we've not had four months yeah because
he's working on working to be able to
bond together was its movement happen
for a reason that's what I do what I do
seen seen stories like this I mean you
know that you probably know I don't I
don't even take a salary from the
training company I do it I mean the
training business is a business but I
take it you can take a salary from it
because hearing stories like that and
being able to impact people's lives yeah
and then see you go and impact other
people's lives and have that rippling
effect what's it been like working with
me over the last couple yes amazing
I mean you you've been an inspiration I
told you I've not just look to you as a
mentor for me you're you're an
entrepreneur and to learn your steps and
how you're doing things what you're
doing it's amazing so anyone thanks
thanks for being with us really every
student get counts you for this every we
count you for this because you're always
giving back to us no matter what dude
it's been great working with you thank
you thank you for coming
cheering you want and hopefully 20 is
like even better than 21 day thank you
respect bro thank you I really hope you
found that interview inspiring
entertaining and enlightening so what is
the advice for you right now personally
I would say just booked onto the
property investors crash course it's
free it's two days it's gonna blow your
freaking socks off and you can get
booked on right here also if you want to
watch Pierce's original interview you
can do that over here and please don't
forget to subscribe over here